- Our flight has gone down.
This is an emergency.
- [Narrator] Survive
together or die alone.
- We're getting off this island.
(radio crackling)
(airplane roaring)
(dramatic music)
- Captain Torrance,
flight commander.
How can I help you?
- Fugitive extradition.
- Well, is he dangerous?
What did he do?
- Homicide, 15 years ago.
- [Torrance] I
don't want to scare
the rest of the passengers.
- [Man] I'm afraid you're
stuck with us, Captain.
- Get 'em on board,
let's have a good flight.
(dramatic music intensifies)
(thunder roars)
Cutting right through
the top of the storm.
(bell dings)
Listen, keep everybody
in their seats.
No exceptions, all right?
(plane rumbling)
- I need everyone
to have their seatbelts
securely fastened!
(dramatic music continues)
- Mayday, mayday, mayday.
Blazer 119, we are dark.
(console beeping)
Does anyone hear us, goddamn it?
- We're gonna hit,
we're gonna hit!
(dramatic music)
(plane roaring)
(suspenseful music)
- They went down somewhere
in the Jolo Island cluster.
It's run by separatists
and militias.
The Filipino army won't
even go there anymore.
The clock is ticking.
Every minute matters.
(clock ticks)
We can count those minutes
in lives lost or saved.
(people shouting)
- Guys, wait, wait.
Get back, we don't
know who it is.
We don't know who
it is, get back!
- Listen carefully.
This is an emergency.
I'm Captain Brodie Torrance.
(gun fires)
(dramatic music)
- I like this guy.
- Name, country!
- Maxwell Carver, England.
- Name, country.
(gun fires)
(people screaming)
- I gotta go after them.
They're my passengers,
my responsibility.
I'm gonna need your help.
- You're gonna need this.
- Former military or something?
- [Louis] You could say that.
- [Torrance] Why'd
they lock you up?
- No one cares what
really happened.
But they say
redemption can be found
in the most unusual places.
(body thudding)
(dramatic music)
If you do this, you'll probably
never see your family again.
- What about their families?
I have a daughter and
I have every intention
of making it home.
(man screams)
They are gonna come at us
with everything they've got.
- [Louis] We're getting
off this island.
(guns firing)
(dramatic music)
(radio crackling)